good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone had
a fabulous stunning beautiful and smart
weekend hey Jax how you doing I'm doing
good happy to be back in studio it was a
great weekend busy weekend tiring
weekend
and now it's just another glorious
Monday could you believe it
no because it feels like a Friday I have
the longest weekend like I'm ready to
now relax but it's Monday
um we haven't been in studio since
Thursday
um well actually since Wednesday because
Thursday we recorded remotely from
Nashville
um I I feel like I've been to the edge
of the Earth and back since that last
show like I'm a different person what's
changed for you just the experiences
I've experienced you know changed you
they've changed me I mean first of all
my show in Nashville was life-changing
like
the way I would literally move to
Nashville is not normal it was so fun
first of all like the show was
incredible it was such a nice theater
shout out to the TPAC it was beautiful
and I was amazing and then I hit the
town afterwards obviously because
Shannon was in town my friend Abe came
with me and it was Nashville so like I
did what I had to do what you do yeah I
went honky tonking on Broadway it was
incredib like the way I don't think I've
ever had more fun in my life than when I
go out in Nashville like why don't I
live there you should move there well if
I lived there like I wouldn't go to
Broadway that's the thing it's like
truly for tourists
but I don't care you would find
somewhere else and you would I think you
would still love it I support you moving
there it was amazing like I love it
there so much the weather was perfect
the people were so nice I had so much
fun I was like out till the break of
dawn came home ate McDonald's like
things I do in New York you know it was
really
just stunning like if you were there to
experience it I'm so glad for you
because it was wonderful like Ugh just
love you love to hear that Claudia
always embarks on her tour she doesn't
know what it's gonna be she's always a
little shy even through her confidence
you can see that there's like a shyness
you know hmm like you know what how you
always say like will people love like I
myself and then she comes back on a
Monday to let us know that she crushed
it that I crushed I'm literally the most
talented comedian on the planet like
nobody can write material better than me
I am the voice of my generation like
that's how I feel when I get off stage
which is good it's better than feeling
like oh my God I'm in the wrong line of
work like do I actually think I'm the
most talented comedian yes
um you know what I mean it's just yeah
you're right like the difference between
like the sh the podcast before a show
and after is so different before I show
it's like I hope you guys come and have
a good time like we're gonna have a lot
of fun yeah like I think you guys are
gonna like it that [ __ ] to the ground we
did we burned that mother down like if
you were there you know like we burned
that to the ground you experience
greatness I experience greatness like
let's do it again
where are we doing it again next time
um so I hate to disappoint everyone but
my last three remaining shows Durham
Charlotte and Birmingham are at 100
capacity I just got the numbers the
other day so there's literally not a
ticket to be sold so you will not catch
me promoting girl with no job.com tour
you won't oh my gosh the show is about
to be like 15 minutes shorter every day
now no the show's about to be 15 minutes
long period yeah I'm so sorry to like be
the bearer of bad news you know I'm sold
out Nationwide I'm sure we could find
something else to promote while we have
this dirt I mean if we had to you know
it's never too late to become a redhead
girl with no job.com
I mean the list the list of Mogul Tings
is endless tiann yes etc
etc speaking of it being never too late
to become a redhead you are a redhead
right now as you are currently reading
our newest book okay I'm sure your
thoughts as you progress I'm reading
lessons in chemistry I'm taking it slow
I haven't had like a ton of time to read
I think I'm about like 50 60 now if you
read the book you know the thing that
happened like crushed me and like I
really did not want to continue reading
the book like why why did they have to
do that that was snatchers POV too that
was so unnecessary like these two
miserable people who had like the only
source of Joy taken from them like
whatever I don't want to spoil them for
anyone I am enjoying it it's a lot of
science like chill with the scientific
analogies like we get it are you a
scientist we get it
um but I am really enjoying it I'm just
doing it slowly I don't know why because
you had a busy weekend yeah so then I
came back Friday headed to the New York
Wine and Food Festival spritzed through
a A bash it was just truly like I I had
nothing to do with the planning so Ben
was just like show up here wear this
like you know and it was so much fun all
the girls came out the influencer
Sevilla court and it was super fun like
the face of Spritz the face of spreads
gorgeous face of Spritz she is a spritz
can personified one thousand percent
bubbly red stunning yeah I love when you
and Margo hang out with her they just
feel like it's um I feel a scene through
osmosis like you're hanging out with her
yeah so you guys still choose to hang
out with redheads only
um and then I ran into Matt Peterson so
he is a tick tocker who I've known is a
toaster he's like literally 10 million
followers on Tick Tock it's crazy what's
his shtick
um okay I'll do it for you
he's like he has just like this food
these food challenges so someone will be
like eat only purple foods for a day so
he'll choose someone's Challenge and be
like challenge accepted and then I'll
take you through the day of like eating
only purple foods and he just moved to
New York so he came to this Prince party
obviously because it was the New York
Wine and Food Festival of course Matt
Peterson had to be there and I knew he
was a toaster I didn't realize how big
of a toaster he was Jackie he was saying
the nicest things and he said something
that like truly stuck with me that I was
like using all weekend because I was
like I was really nervous about bravocon
he was like I need to tell you something
like you guys have to stop talking about
like your haters because you don't
realize like there are so many people
who love you guys we like literally
would take a bullet for you you're such
an important part of our day like stop
talking about the four haters you have
so many lovers and I'm like you're so
right like I was like it's just human
nature you know like you focus on the
negative like there could be a hundred
people in a room it's yes it's human
nature and there's a million people in
the room I think like we are
particularly traumatic ties yes but that
is such amazing advice and that's
literally the advice like we always give
other people other people take ourselves
and I've really never thought about it
like that no Jackie and he was like
literally screaming at me but he was
totally he's like stop stop and I'm like
okay okay I'll stop he was totally right
oh my God I'm obsessed obsessed with
this change of perspective so that was
kind of the shift in my weekend you know
like that was like a whole new me that's
what I'm saying a new girl new
experiences oh my God I'm I'm loving
where you're taking us
so then Saturday I woke up and I finally
went to Pennsylvania to meet Brian's son
Dean
um it was literally the nicest Day first
of all like fall is in full effect and
as much as I'm like there's so many
aspects of your new life that I'm
jealous of of course you know having a
pool Harry like a lot of different
things uh you not having the seasons
like it sucks like we were driving up it
was so sick it's so sick and when I was
moving to Florida people are like oh my
gosh the weather's so amazing I'm like
that's actually my least favorite part
about thinking about moving to Florida
it's like I I love the seasons I I like
the cold and I'll suffer through those
two miserable months you know I'm living
literally two months for ten and no
you're living yeah yeah yeah it's worth
oh I love it all and so to me like the
weather in Florida is actually a
negative not a positive for most people
it's a positive you know it's summer 24
7 you can always swim I still haven't
been in my pool since you were here in
August I'm coming back maybe sometime
this week I probably won't be in my I
pull again until you come back well I'll
make sure to pack my trunks bring your
swimsuit
um so we just drove up to Pennsylvania
and it was so beautiful like I literally
was like sobbing on the way there it's
just like you only get like a month
maybe less of like a transition of the
transition so it's still a little green
yellow it was so beautiful it was like
such a peaceful drive and then we got up
to Brian's Farm which he's done like so
much renovation and construction on and
the trees were just it was so Red by
Taylor Swift and I met baby Dean and he
was so [ __ ] cute and Brian had the
nursery and it was just like so amazing
and we had lunch you know John grilled
and it was just like a stunning day we
watched her on the property saw the
horses and then right before we left we
watched Brian's birth video so Brian
surrogate's wife kind of like filmed the
whole thing on an iPhone like nothing
crazy but we put it on airplane we
watched it and it wasn't like super
um
graphic graphic thank you uh she was
standing you know at like a normal
angle but
um I think Ben was like I have seen a
birth before like I once ran into a
toaster and she showed me her water
birth and that was honestly [ __ ]
chopstizing I've never I've given birth
and I've never seen I don't know what it
looks like I've never watched a video of
it I didn't know what like I only saw
what I could see and and I think that's
how it's supposed to be did you look at
your coochie I did as much as I could
um but I couldn't I'm not an acrobat
like no no yeah like I can't like right
you're pregnant oh there's a the baby is
in my way right so there was like twice
where she was like come and look so I
did as much as I could and it was like
cool stuff nothing crazy but like Zach
was like that's so crazy so we watch a
video as a baby's coming out they like
you know immediately bring baby to
Brian's Second Skin we're all like
sobbing it was really like you could
totally in the video it captured like
the specialness of that moment and Brian
was saying how like a lot of you know it
wasn't in Cedar Sinai was kind of
outside LA and so you know they don't
have a lot of surrogacy there and so
um everyone like the nurses and everyone
was crying like it was like so emo it
was so beautiful so right after that we
left we drove back to the city and Ben
was like dead [ __ ] silent in the car
I'm like what is wrong Ben he's so much
he's so chatty especially in a moving
vehicle
he was like I just I can't talk like I
need to process what I just saw I'm like
oh my God it like wasn't even that crazy
like I don't even have a particularly
strong stomach it just it wasn't that
crazy he was dead silent for the first
45 minutes of the car ride like he could
not speak
yeah I don't I don't feel like people
need to watch birth videos I feel like
by the like by the time you give birth
like every your body has done such like
incredible amazing things it's like
what's pushing out a human and even like
for your husband so like if Ben saw you
give birth like he also had seen you
like create a child for 10 months it's
like
it's it's very Stark to go from being a
lay person to watching a birth yeah I
don't think you need to watch a birth to
like prepare yourself for it but it was
like a nice moment I'm glad I got to see
from Brian's life you know not
everyone's cut out for it but that's
what I was taking away I wasn't looking
for like you know anatomical assistance
no I was just like oh my God this is so
special I actually wish I could have
been there but now I got a video you
know yeah so it was such a nice day and
then me and Ben just came home and
chilled because the next day I was doing
bravocon so we drove home we got stuck
in bumper-to-bumper traffic going into
the Lincoln Tunnel and Ben um had a
Moonstruck moment which if you listen to
the toes you know that means he thought
he was going to [ __ ] his pants and we
pulled off and like we were driving
around you know like right before you
get into the tunnel there's nothing
there like we were driving around we
were Ben was screaming like
we finally ended up at some random like
it was called Bonefish Grill Ben got to
poo and that was the end of our day then
we went to bed woke up super early
yesterday for bravocon so I knew I was
moderating this panel at Bravo con and I
was like really [ __ ] nervous like
honestly it kind of ruined my weekend
knowing that I had to do it because I
had this pit like I was really nervous
about it the whole time
um and I wasn't sure why but then once I
got there like I realized why the
magnitude like the event it's 10 000
people it's at the Javits Center it's
huge it's like this huge undertaking and
the second you walk in I saw literally
within four steps I saw Naomi Craig
Austin Kyle Richards so many different
people Patricia alchill like it was
really overwhelming and it was kind of
crazy to be there because
you know everyone who's becomes a Bravo
Liberty like immediately gets like this
big ego I think and they all think
they're like the biggest star on their
show so then to be in a room with all
these other big stars it was kind of
like
a dick measuring contest yes yeah
exactly like and I saw a lot of people
being nice to one another I saw a lot of
people ignoring one another for a Bravo
fan it was incredibly overwhelming like
you I couldn't go to the bathroom
without seeing 45 people it was crazy I
saw a res I can't even Jackie
goldschneider like I can't even count
the people McSweeney
um and then I got to meet everyone for
my panel so my panel was all about the
iconic vacations that they've taken so
we heard from Candace Dillard Bessette
Kyle Richards Kenya Moore and Luann de
lesseps and then also um four producers
from each of their shows talking about
like how they plan and how they film
those trips did they talk about who pays
for it
um no but we did talk about like why
Beverly Hills seems to always be flying
private when everyone's flying
commercial and Kyle was like because we
paid for it okay so the ladies paid for
it okay fair is fair and I think that
really settled the rest of the group
Kenya was like yeah why
and they were like well we paid for it
and everyone was like oh okay well that
makes sense at least you're not getting
special treatment right
um so the panel went great we had great
conversations it was so interesting to
see how like the crowd receives
different Housewives I mean I could have
told you this but seeing it in person
like the way the room lost their mind
over Luanne like she's such a star and I
think in the context of this
conversation vacations she really comes
to mind as you know be cool is that a
buffalo coming down the stairs eggsella
Francais the pirate don't be all uncool
like she has all these iconic moments
falling into the bush so everyone was
really lit to see her and for me I've
met Kyle and I've met Luanne I had never
met Candace and I never met Kenya and
you know I watched Potomac religiously
and I'm not a particular like Candace
fan but after meeting her I have to say
like
obsessed she was of all the ladies the
nicest to me like chatting taking
pictures like so kind so lovely and then
when I was watching last night's Potomac
like I found myself being like drawn to
her but that happens all the time I mean
same with Kenya from the show yep like
when they come on the toast and you you
get a really good feeling from them it
influences how you see them on the show
because you're able to just like put
them into context and like
I think it's a good thing when that
happens it humanizes that no and to have
more of like a
picture of this person so I'm so here
for changing hearts and Minds yeah Kenya
was incredible like I'm obsessed the way
that like you know it really showed me
and I think it's so important to always
remember like you don't know the people
that you're watching on TV like you
literally know nothing about them yeah
it was awesome it was so cool to be
asked like honestly like I was really
honored
um I'm glad it's behind me because I was
like so nervous about it and there were
so many toasters there which just made
like it was a very welcoming environment
which I really appreciated that's so
nice well it was a fabulous weekend
jam-packed weekend for you jam-packed
weekend for you how was your weekend I'm
tired of talking my weekend was a little
different you know it was very home
focused whenever Harry was napping I was
either just reading or cooking but a few
exciting updates from the weekend that
I'll share one on Friday morning we took
Harry to get his passport which was just
like the cutest when I tell you I've
showed every single picture people that
picture every single person that picture
sorry I'm like having a seizure of his
passport picture it he's literally a
lump of potatoes like he's just skin in
the picture it's just like a potato uh
dress like acting like a big man you
know totally cosplaying
um also something really exciting that
happened this weekend was that Harry
said Mama oh
my God yes and I've also showed one
million people that video sorry so on
Saturday morning when I um when he woke
up and I went to get him from his crib
like I'm pretty I thought I heard him
say mama but like no one was around and
you know I didn't have it on video so I
was like oh maybe his like mouth just
made Mama whatever I didn't think too
much of it but then later I've also been
noticing that when he plays with Brew or
like sees brew and I'm always saying
Brother Bruno Brother Bruno Mars there's
Brew where's Brew I just say Bruno all
the time I've been noticing that he's
like trying to say Bruno it's obviously
not gonna be a baby's first word it's
kind of hard but he's like it is he'll
say boo yeah and so like we were eating
and just like playing and Zach and I
were like Bruno he's like Boo no boom we
were doing that for a while and then
Zach just decided to switch it up and he
was like dada and I was like please and
Harry goes mama you guys the video like
like changed my life like Not only was
it like you know a lot of kids say mama
now I'm not saying Harry's special but I
think he might be because he literally
literally had such enunciation we
basically said mother like not even that
like he swerved on his father yeah that
was the best part you think I'm gonna
say Dada before mama when this woman
birthed me did you see a birthing video
yet father you father
it was literally so perfectly enunciated
it wasn't like it was
literally like Jason Momoa
even he couldn't ruin the moment so that
it was Perfection like when I say when I
tell you I watch a video no less than 45
000 times I'm obsessed literal
genius it was really really cute and
then really exciting was last night the
snatchler came over oh yeah because she
was in town for work she requested I
make a chili which you know I'm never
going to turn down I did a different
chili than the one from last week
because the Shapiro's did come over and
I don't want them to get sick of my
cooking so I did um a beef chili from
Half Baked Harvest love her recipes and
it was a big hit like Kaylor literally
is obsessed with my cooking like there
could be chips on the plate I made a
corn muffin her plate is full of like
yummy carbs only eating the chili
that's our carnivorous girly and she is
like the only critic that I care about
their opinion she's the only voice that
matters in The Culinary industry The
only voice that matters and I think it
was Friday night oh I cooked Friday
night too I see a lot of cooking this
weekend I made stuffed peppers taco
stuffed peppers so good I was the only
one who ate the stuffed peppers everyone
else just had tacos
um but I really enjoyed and I'll be
having stuffed peppers for lunch for
months no I have two more I will be
having it for lunch and dinner it sounds
like we had such different weekends and
like I'm like so jealous of your weekend
just because like family food and fun
you know
you were missed though because you know
the sisters were together last night
having chili and
you you would have loved it
that's sweet and it just had a reading
update I finished my book tomorrow
tomorrow and tomorrow I could say
objectively it's a good book but I
personally didn't love it
um but it was it's a good book it's
obviously amazingly well written it just
I was saying Mr Claudia just filled me
with like existential dread and I don't
feel that way when I read a lot of books
but I was just feeling like Dreadful
that's how I feel honestly about every
new episode I watch of tell me lies
yeah it's positively Dreadful it's just
like
it was so
pessimistic and like just like sad and
just like never really got really to be
great even though these were kids who
were having like so much success and
like just like couldn't enjoy life and I
just love a little Joy David you know
it's so important that every book I read
has a certain element of and just leaves
me with a bit of what to be but then I'm
also reading I'm almost done with the
only woman in the room by Marie Benedict
it's historical fiction and it's the
story of Hedy Lamarr who is an iconic
Queen but her backstory is so
interesting she's an Austrian jewess who
escapes right before the breakout of
World War II and goes on to Hollywood to
become a huge actress and an inventor
she's like the most gorgeous woman and
the smartest woman get you a woman who
could do both and her story so what
you're saying is that she's beautiful
sending and smart literally beautiful
stunning and smart and I haven't
finished reading it yet so I don't want
to Google yet but a quick Google because
I wanted to see a picture of her cause
I'm like this beautiful woman let me see
uh showed me that Gal Gadot will be
playing her in a series on Showtime of
course she will our Jewish Queen Gal
Gadot coming in to preserve history and
to play a fellow Jewish Queen I also
love reading books about like the time
before like between 1933 and 1939 so
like the war hadn't broken out yet but
like the Nazis are on the move and like
you know Nuremberg laws are going into
place anti-Semitism is like crazy on the
rise and like I know in hindsight
everyone sit like thinks that they would
do the right thing and like stand up for
like people who are being oppressed
oppressed but like it's so interesting
to but they didn't to hear to like see
what actually happened during that time
and how like everyone just like went
along with it cheered for it like when
Austria when Germany invaded Austria
they didn't even have to invade everyone
was cheering in the streets there was no
military presence they just absorbed
Austria and
it's um
it's just crazy yeah like if you're ever
like what actually happened if you ever
do one of those trips like to Poland
um like a March of the living there are
all these trips you can go on and like
learn about the Holocaust visit
concentration camps Auschwitz is
obviously like a museum now
um and one of the craziest parts of that
trip is they'll show you how like all
these there's so many different
facilities that were used to like
kill and you know enslave Jews and so
many of them are like literally in the
middle of a suburb like you're standing
in what used to be like a gas chamber
and right across the street is like a
nice Suburban you know street with five
homes on it and people used to just
chill while all that was going on yeah
also like the last count I think it was
like the New York Times discovered that
there were 40 000 concentration in death
camps across Europe during World War II
like that's not something that like a
few crazy people you can hide no and
it's not like this is like mass
production
people are okay with it like it's it's
wild to think about and also like you
don't just go from like
Hitler being uh elected to death camps
like there's an almost 10-year period
where like it's all of these small
things that happen along the way that
nobody
stops or nobody speaks out against that
allow for you to get to that final
solution mm-hmm
well we've got bravocon and
concentration camps here for you today
and that's who you can expect at the
morning toast the unexpected the
unexpected but that's what happens when
you're a reader like you're just
expanding your horizons constantly
expanding your horizons so well there
was a lot of news that came out of that
book what was it called again the only
woman in the room Marie Benedict
fabulous uh historical fiction writer
also wrote personal librarian chef's
kiss there was a ton of news that came
out of bravocon so we're going to talk
about all of that and just uh the
general musings from the weekend Lots
going on and then we also have House of
the Dragon recap at the end of today's
episode and a little Potomac there's
really nothing going on in Potomac so
it'll be a 40 second recap
um but House of the Dragon second to
last the penultimate I love that word
the penultimate is always [ __ ]
snatched we had the 9th out of tenth
episode of House of the Dragon last
night so of course your girlies are
going to be recapping that for you at
the end of today's episode you truly
don't want to miss it no you don't so
without further
do Where Are You Bruno misses his auntie
where is do what did he do all weekend
I love you Theo was at his grandparents
I'm happy for you can't wait till he's
with his auntie
I need Brew we need to discuss when I'm
coming to you
loves you he said where's my auntie okay
I know this is probably like not podcast
fodder but I don't need to pack any food
for Theo right you saw that big bag or
did Bruno eat all of it he ate some of
it but uh you don't need to pack also I
meant to send you a picture this weekend
I forget why it didn't Bruno went into
your bed
like I I caught him there it was like
pitch black you're kidding he like ran
out I turned on the lights he was like
getting into the pillows it's like
unmade because Brew was looking for you
leave it yeah I'm shook I know I I meant
to send you the picture also speaking of
I'm shook there's a new episode of Good
Guys which there is every Monday but
today Ben was in LA last week so they
recorded a bunch of episodes together
and the one they recorded today has Cody
Co on it which is like look at them
getting premium like A-list guests one
month into podcasting I guess it's the
power of Josh pack up probably
um so check that out it's anywhere you
get your podcast it's up right now I
listened to it last night I was cracking
up because they're all like well Cody is
engaged but they're all like you know
married guys yeah and Ben was saying the
funniest thing he was like I am so
grateful to be married because like I
was The Biggest Loser before I got
married like my wife totally saved me
and Josh was like well why do you think
you were a loser and Ben was like
because I had no confidence like I
couldn't get any girls like I literally
thought I was like an ugly like I had no
confidence and he's like well now like I
have so much confidence like my wife
gives me so much confidence like if I
was single I'd be slaying it was a
really good conversation and Cody's just
the best so it's really sweet it was
sweet they're like because you know what
they really are like the good guys they
were just talking about how like married
life is awesome like they're so cute
that's really cute I I'm gonna listen to
it but I feel like that's a really good
message to get out there I feel like the
good guys are good Role Models not what
you typically hear you know no and you
know like about how monogamy is not
natural
[ __ ] this weekend and they all have
like open marriages and like yeah no
they're making monogamy cool
I love that and if there's like a guy
that you're talking to and like you want
him to like start kind of settling down
maybe maturing suggest good guys I think
it'll really help like that you know
late 20s guy Bachelor who's like maybe
close to transitioning into like a
settling down period of his life I think
it could help send them the good guys
pod oh my God I love I love the work
that they're doing
so now without further Ado here are the
fastest five stories that you need to
know on this glorious Monday
I like that
today's episode is brought to you by
Clinique thank you Clinique for
sponsoring today's episode their first
Foundation is designed to be the last
step in your skincare routine it's the
even better better clinical serum
Foundation it is formulated with three
serum Technologies and it visibly
reduces dark spots it brightens and it
hydrates your skin so
Clinique is obviously like a skincare
brand that you can trust and I love when
makeup and Skin Care Collide because
they really should if you're going to be
putting all the Schmutz on your face all
day it might as well be working in your
favor and that's why the Clinique
clinical serum Foundation is fabulous
because it's built with skin care
technology inside of it and in in as
little as eight weeks a lot of people
had even more toned skin radiant skin
and smoother after their makeup is
removed calling it a foundation doesn't
really do it justice because it's a
clinical Foundation built with three
serum Technologies and it doesn't just
cover your skin it completes your
regimen by visibly correcting hydrating
and smoothing the look of skin with
everywhere also the packaging is really
sustainable because it is um made of
glass so the glass bottle can be
recycled you just remove the cap and the
pump and then the glass bottle goes in
the recycling bin um it's also just
stunning like if you have a vanity my
thing is you know see-through so I don't
like to buy ugly makeup products and the
Clinique Foundation is like this
stunning glass bottle it's giving like
Rich Coastal grandmother and it's
something you could be really proud to
have on your vanity you don't have to
tuck it away like some of those ugly
other foundations so the hydrating
formula is buildable it has a medium to
full coverage with a satin finish it has
a feather light feather light weight
texture 24 hour color true wear and it
is oil free waterproof sweat and
humidity resistant it's non-acnegenic
non-caking non-settling increasing
non-poring and non-streaking one of the
best parts is that it comes in 42 Shades
which is obviously a huge range so you
can find a shade for yourself also
they've got this great technology online
Me and Jackie both did it took like four
seconds you can find your shade using
the Clinique clinical reality shade
match science so it's a virtual try on
it was hella easy like I thought it was
one of the best shade matches I've
gotten without being in the store and it
was fabulous don't call it makeup it is
skin care just in your shade find your
shade today at clinique.com today's
episode is also sponsored by away
perfect timing because I'm headed to Jax
and I'm always bringing my away suitcase
when I'm
when Jackson Claude are being reunited
so obviously you guys know a way they
make suitcases bags and other travel
Essentials that are designed to make
moving through the world a lot more
seamless it's a good thing because when
you travel you become a better person
more well-rounded and a way is just
going to help you do that in a more
seamless way they offer a range of
travel products to solve real travel
problems and get you out there so their
most popular item of course are their
suitcases Jackie and I both have the
carry-on the bigger carry-on and the
checked I can't get enough I feel like I
get a new one every couple of months
because I just need more got one for Ben
recently then I actually left one at
Olivia's house because I just feel like
when I go down to Florida I'm always
like going to the mall and then I just
need a suitcase so I have one in
Olivia's garage it's fabulous I also
think they've been using it behind my
back which is fine I'm not upset God
forbid they ask but it's fine
um and why they're great is because
they're made of different materials like
polycarbonate and aluminum and it comes
in a variety of colors and sizes so
whatever you're packing wherever you're
going away has luggage that will make
your trip more seamless all other
suitcases are built to last with durable
lightweight exteriors that can withstand
even the roughest a bag of Chandlers
every suitcase comes with an interior
organization system which has a perfect
little compact place for your dirty
undies because there is no travel issue
more pressing than where to put your
dirty undies and Away suitcase not only
gives you a laundry bag but they also
have this little thing in the middle
that has like a little zipper and I feel
like that's a great place to put your
dirty on these but to each their own
obviously they have four wheels that are
360 degree spinner Wheels it guarantees
a smooth roll even through the most
hectic of airports like LaGuardia which
is now covered front to back in carpet
which is a disgrace
they also have a TSA approved
combination lock so you can keep all of
your stuff safe and it comes with a
sleeve that slides over your suitcase so
uh if you're putting it in storage you
won't get all scuffed up they offer free
shipping and returns to any uh
non-personalized orders within the
contiguous U.S Canada and the UK and
they have a 100-day free trial on
everything that they make so you can
take the product on the road with you
live with it laugh with it love with it
travel with it get lost with it and
after 100 days if you decide that it's
not for you you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period so start your 100-day
trial and Shop the entire lineup of
travel Essentials including their
best-selling suitcases and bags at
awaytravel.com toast that's
awaytravel.com toast
great thank you our first story is Big
bravocon recap the biggest headlines
moments exclusives
Etc in no particular order here's an uh
article from in touch weekly with some
of the biggest moments that we'll break
down first the new Roni cast was
revealed
I'm pleasantly surprised yeah real
houses in New York not legacy this is
the new reboot with fresh cast has been
revealed uh cast members are Uber Hassan
Giselle tank Erin lychee Jen Alliance Cy
de Silva and Brad Whitfield as well as
Lizzy savesky but she wasn't at bravocon
because of the Jewish holiday
so I obviously I feel like a lot of
people have known that Lizzy savesky is
going to be on Brony I feel like she was
one of the first people cast and I think
maybe some of these girls are her
friends
um the I think the big shocker for
everyone's Jenna Lions former president
of J.Crew she's like kind of like a
fashion icon yeah and that's like a
pretty good get honestly like a pretty
good get that was the only name that I
knew personally but I think besides
Lizzy besides Lizzy I checked out a lot
of the other women I think all of them
some of them have followings they all
have premium content yeah no I feel I
have I feel optimistic me too because
even though I hadn't heard of them I did
like a little Deep dive on what they all
do for a living their husbands and it
was giving rich and it was giving young
and it was giving social media and I
feel like that's kind of a show people
have been like begging for from Bravo
and you know the Bravo fandom like I was
reading the comments on Bravo's
Instagram like people are so negative
um because they're used to the ogs
they're like bring Sonya back well Sonia
probably is gonna be on Legacy so like
that's not for forget that what I did
find interesting about this was this was
an official you know um
statement that Leah McSweeney is not a
part of the new show I feel like there
was still
some questions as to whether because
she's young and hip and cool well she
said on the toast that she wants to be
on Legacy of course those are her
friends and like that's going to be it's
gonna take a while for this show to get
its legs a new show is always hard to
get off the ground so she wants to be
with the established girlies yeah what I
also like about this cast is like I feel
like there were so many names throwing
out so many obvious choices for people
who are New York social media young
housewives but these for most of us are
all fresh faces and I like that they're
doing something different and not just
like going with like a safe person
because they have followers or what I
also like with some of those choices but
like I'm here for the fact that they
didn't go down that route yeah but I
also like that they have like a big name
you know like they need that yeah Jenna
lines I think that's really cool
um I also think it's so admirable that
like you know obviously they all went to
bravocon they had a picture with Andy it
was like a big thing and Lizzy savitski
didn't go because it's
yeah I forget which holiday it is it's
like kind of a niche one that I don't
really um participate in but
um that's like hella admirable because
like it could be Yom Kippur but like
they want me to be the star of a show
like gotta go you know like yeah it's
cool she seems uh scrupled I've actually
met her she's a lovely lovely girl group
old first she scribbled so that's very
cool
um I honestly I was ready to like come
and be a hater but
it seems like they did a pretty good job
honestly yeah no I'm optimistic as
stated and Bravo has needed for a while
I feel like and we are always the type
who are like wait this like clean you
need fresh this is bad bad so like
they're trying something new they
actually answered some of the cries of
some of the fans and so let's give them
the opportunity for to see how it is you
know you can't just complain all the
time no and Andy did uh one of the
events yesterday was it was actually at
the same time as mine so I was like kind
of like sad because I'm like no it's
gonna come to mine it was ask Andy where
basically he just was like free-for-all
like whatever you want to know
um and they were talking about Roni and
you know all the people who are at Bravo
con are like fans of the OG show and
they're like complaining
and Andy was like I hear you but like
the numbers don't lie this was the
lowest rated season in Housewives
history not just New York of all
franchises like something had to be done
and I feel like Bravo's been on this
Housewives Journey for like 15 years and
the people who started watching it like
everyone's aging up in the last 15 years
and if they want to continue to get new
younger
audience members like they have to
evolve a little bit you know right at
the end of the day this is still a
business you know and it's not just like
what a handful of people want to see on
their TV like there's advertisers you
need to bring in people who are watching
you know a lot of advertisers want to
advertise to a certain demographic of
people so if all of your audience is a
bit older that's not going to bring in
the premium dollars like this is a
business and right the numbers don't lie
and the numbers he said like pretty much
what he's saying is you guys are the
reasons why there's no Roni as it is
anymore because you guys didn't watch by
the way you know what I thought was so
interesting how Ramona was non-existent
in bravocon dude was she there I don't
think so maybe it was she was
celebrating
no like
a good one
um let me just check because I was
thinking yesterday I'm like where is
Ramona
I think oh no she was at one day ago she
went to like a party oh she went I'm
sorry I'm totally wrong I'm sorry she
was there just I just feel like she
wasn't it looked like she wasn't
participating I was like consuming
content all weekend and I didn't see her
even once oh that's so interesting
that's so not like Ramona okay here's
some more news that we got some spin-off
news Luanne and Sony are getting their
own spin-off series called Welcome to
crappy Lake which is set to Premiere in
2023 we knew that they were doing a
simple life type show cool uh Teresa and
Louie are having a wedding special uh
following the show's next season Lala
Kent spilled on her sex life saying I'm
having the best sex of my life which I
mean compared to my old relationship Oh
I thought you were talking about a
spin-off no no no oh sorry that leva's
spin-off too about Republic yeah and
they uh aired the trailer for love a
spin-off during the last part of the
Southern Charm reunion which I did watch
oh oh so it was already out I feel like
the last bravocon like the big
announcements were like kind of huge
yeah and like these announcements were
like kind of like some a lot of them
there was already like Whispers we kind
of already knew the Roni cast we knew
about we knew we knew Leva we knew that
Louis and Teresa were having a I mean
that's just common sense but I do feel
like this bravocon was so much bigger
than the last one you know especially in
terms of like the breadth of people they
invited from Bravo like I feel like it
was a little bit more selective but like
Reza was there you thought it was
definitely no the prior year I felt like
it was way more selected whereas this
year Reza and MJ day who I adore and I'm
not complaining but their show was
literally canceled you know like every
cast member of Southern Charm even if
they're not main cast members were there
yeah it was a little person was there
and I wonder like does Bravo pay for all
of them to come yes I think they pay for
everyone's flight and hotel I don't
think you get paid yeah
to participate but you if you have a
business you get to have a booth there
and you make I mean it's 10 000 people
who bought tickets so 10 000 people who
are obsessed with you wanting to buy
whatever you know your Robin's hats or
you know like yeah it's a it's a they
really it's a very smart business idea
yes then also that I think is one of the
biggest news uh from the weekend was
Luke from summer house and Ashley Darby
like flirting and ship
holding hands and leaving together a
ship like even if it's just for the
night like Ashley Darby deserves to have
some fun yeah really cute really cute
and of course like the everyone is
talking about Teresa and Melissa because
they're fully on the out they had to
split up the Jersey uh panels they did
not see each other and then everyone
like the everyone was staying pretty
much at like the same hotel and late
night Melissa no no what's her name
Jennifer Aiden threw a drink at Joe
Gorga they weren't even filming like
real life
so like shit's bad shit's bad but I
gotta be honest like that's not gonna
work
um when you have two cast members who
actually can't be in the same room
together won't even do a panel and by
the way like this is like the the
networks event like and they can't do a
panel together how are they gonna film
the next season together we can't have a
disjointed season where there's like two
groups it doesn't work like they're
gonna have for the sake of like their
jobs they're gonna have to figure out
yeah which is also a nice thing about
the show because it will force them
eventually to talk whereas like if they
were both off the show starting from now
they would never speak again yeah and
that reminds me of Kathy and Kyle I saw
a couple interviews Kyle said you know
we're sisters like we're we're we're
fine like we're working on it like we're
gonna be fine Kathy said I will she
literally said point blank to an
interviewer I will not be returning next
season if it's the exact same cast and
he was like I assume you mean Lisa she
said yes so she's literally making an
ultimatum between the network and I feel
like the network is gonna choose Kathy
like I think the network is gonna choose
Kathy and no but Kathy was being so
reasonable she was like by the way and I
know like I'm just a friend of so like
it doesn't matter right but people [ __ ]
like it's unprecedented how much they
love her they love her myself included
Lisa Rena got booed when she was walking
on stage but I feel like that's you know
we're in a kind of like she doesn't mind
that you know no I thought she handled
it beautifully she didn't see everyone
the finger and she's laughing it off I'm
sure somewhere down like it does of
course it's my worst nightmare I think
for her like she'd rather be booed
vehemently than be like irrelevant
clapping you know what I mean like she
likes to have an impact act but it is
kind of like sad
um and so you could see Lisa Rena is not
beloved right now and Kathy Hilton is
unprecedented they did the conga line
for her TV party like
obsessed no Kathy and by the way the
thing I love most about Kathy Hilton it
happened to me this morning
um like every couple of days she like
stalks me and she likes every single one
of the posts that she missed since the
last time she's so supportive it's so
amazing and another
um I have to shout out to Bryce sander
who works at Entertainment Tonight like
he was a correspondent on the carpet and
every clip that I saw that was like full
of pertinent information he was talking
to this person he was asking pertinent
questions yeah because on the first
night he was like you know Andy there's
like a million conspiracy theories that
like the big announcement this year is
like you're retiring and Craig Conover
is taking over for you I saw that and
Andy was like um no and even if I was
like why Craig like I love Craig but
he's not one of our you know he's not
known as one of our best correspondents
right and he's like no I'm not retiring
and honestly I have felt like in the
last couple of years Andy's enthusiasm
for his job has
gone down a little bit but I felt like
he was like he had the best weekend of
his life like everything I saw he was
having so much fun he really did like he
did the most this weekend I felt like
his he has a reinvigorated love for what
he does yeah that's nice to see he also
Andy said that there's no Kathy Hilton
meltdown footage
um he said you know that I'm a shade
assassin I'm going to want to show it if
I was having a producer if it was if the
footage was on a producer phone we would
show it trust me yeah and I believe that
they don't have any footage but that's
unacceptable yeah also Kyle Cook
revealed his Bravo Hall Pass
he said I'm gonna go super controversial
on this one maybe Naomi from Southern
Charm that's like a little too close
yeah I agree but you know what her and
Amanda kind of look like so Amanda can
take that as a compliment is that he
still wants Amanda
I guess you know but still that's like
kind of weird extremely awesome like
really weird questions I just saw a clip
of Erica James yes they asked like who's
gonna be the next couple to split up and
she said she didn't want to answer and
then she said to eat in PK but you also
have to think of who are the couples on
the show
Kyla Mauricio Crystal and Rob
dyrdom PK
um here's a personality are there any
others of dorit I went let me tell you I
went over to Kyle right before the panel
I was like hey girlie I'm your moderator
and she was like oh hi and then Jerry
was there and dorit's hoop earring fell
out
and Kyle was like Dory you're she was
wearing like this huge poofy skirt she
like to read your earrings on the floor
you're about to step on it so you know
I'm a young able-bodied girly and she
was wearing like this huge ball gown so
I bent down I didn't she didn't ask I
just bent down picked up her earring and
gave it to her when I tell you she did
not even look me in the eyes or say
thank you I'm like oh my God
it was like it but it wasn't rude she
was like
like thank you are the words you're
looking for wench
I did see Karen Huger too and I was like
just about to defend her
she's about to defend her marriage no
I'm sure her marriage is fine but uh
rude
isn't it rude yeah
thank you like I just bent down you
didn't even ask me I don't even know you
I picked up your earring
that's rude rude uh and I'm guessing
that Erica and dorit aren't chummy
currently I didn't see them together I
saw them both separately
um dorit and Kyle like are totally best
friends like you can tell they were
together even though they weren't like
on the same panel they were walking
around together
um but it's just like everyone came with
like their own Posse and it was like
literally like standoffs like it was so
interesting it's so interesting even
like there was that one night where
everyone was on stage and it just like
turns into like this big like ego it was
like Jerry Springer like they're always
like oh and it's like but everyone there
like thinks that lives for the star of
this show yes and like everyone's like
so dressed to the nines and so intense
like the stakes are so high and they're
also like shading each other and it's
like nonsense shade it's like a circus
it's a circus it is I am looking forward
to the watch weapons live specials that
they taped because I think those
episodes are really good and fun yeah
Caroline Manzo was there that's like
another example of like how why'd they
cast The Net yeah
so it was a you know a very eventful
weekend I think Bravo put on a great
oh event I think people had a lot of fun
story was that like the people who had
bought tickets were complaining about
um the way that it was run there was
like some footage that was out and then
people were comparing it to fire
Festival which is one of my least
favorite comparisons because like Blink
182 never took the stage at fire
festival yet like all of these panels
did go off but they were really lying
long lines for the bathroom there was
like a lot of chaos I think for people
who bought tickets
um
so that's all a long line for the
bathroom that's not something to
complain about like it's annoying for
sure anytime I go to a Broadway play
anytime I go to a sports game like it's
really annoying it's not inhumane and
that's not fire festival at all and I
walked around yesterday and it seemed
like they really like they had a million
people working there I didn't experience
it for three days so I don't know for a
fact but it looked like it was pretty
well put together yeah it was just like
people said quote waiting in lines for
panels only for there to be stampedes
and no chairs people camping out all day
to not let others in no use of the RFID
bands it's a [ __ ] show in a video okay
that sounds like hordes by the rebel
fans racing forward and ducking under
barriers at the um entrance on Friday
that sounds like the chaos is because of
the attendees not because of Bravo like
it's it said Bravo had stanchions and a
line and nobody followed it that's
like Bravo can't make people act behave
right yeah they had stanchions right
there was a line for a reason like they
knew there was going to be a lot of
people so that's like
kind of not their fault I will never
remember the word stanchion I know I
can't believe I just did no you said it
I know I said I can't believe it it's
like not in my vocabulary and it like
refuses to stay there I understand like
you could ask me tomorrow like what are
the things that they had to I'll ask you
tomorrow ask me tomorrow and I won't
know the word Fab
see you tomorrow see you tomorrow okay
so that's your bravocon recap hope
everyone had a great weekend yeah truly
next up the big news of the weekend
Haley Bieber poses with Selena Gomez
weeks after addressing rumors that she
quote stole Justin Bieber so Haley
Bieber is keeping an eye out for Selena
at the Academy Music Museum of Motion
Pictures Museum
Museum second annual Gala on Saturday
night in La so not only did they take
this one picture together there's like
no pictures there's a mug there's a hug
the way that like it's not just one
stage photo it's like once they're
sitting once they're standing one um
Selena has her hand around Haley's thigh
leg Yeah like the way that it's multiple
photos like I'm so overjoyed and what's
so funny do you remember this event from
last year we have to watch this episode
from last year because we were like what
the [ __ ] is this and that was where Kaya
Gerber went with Jacob we were like what
is this random event why is it literally
the mecca why is it so A-list wise
everyone looking so fashionable and
stylish the museum and now this year
everyone again is like what is this
event it's the second annual fabulous
event right fabulous people and a
fabulous press up for Kaya Gerber I
think the Gerber's put on the event so
that Kaya can always have an amazing
moment because a moment she's two for
two hundred percent it looked so
fabulous of course the Selena thing
eclipsed entire event and I'm I'm so
glad and I really hope that like anyone
who's ever said the words Jelena in the
last five years officially shuts the
[ __ ] up
yeah and I hope this is the thing to do
and I don't know what more could be done
aside from like Selena you know saying a
whole thing but I think that would also
just like Stir It Up and make it more
real so I think them just like being
girls taking pictures they clearly had
more than just that one moment they had
a conversation and they seem to be happy
and enjoying each other's company and
you I'm so happy about this like I
really can't put into words like I know
it's not plausible that they would ever
become like really good friends but like
they're just like making peace but I
just I love these two so much and I
think it's in their [ __ ] like you know
um
what's the word setting a fabulous
example for young women I love these two
with my whole heart and I'm I'm thrilled
I'm Overjoyed yes nature is healing
nature is healing they both looked
absolutely stunning just really gorgeous
really really gorgeous so hopefully
we'll be seeing Selena and Haley
Bieber's bathroom oh
etc
etc
totally not anytime soon but you never
know we gotta start somewhere and you
know where I'm gonna start there with um
that's right before we continue on with
today's episode let me introduce you to
our sponsor thuma your bed deserves a
refresh and now is the perfect time to
elevate the most important room in your
home with thuma introducing the bed by
thuma handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood you'll find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain the minimalist design
featuring Japanese joinery helps Elevate
any space it's super supportive for your
mattress it's breathable and it's made
to naturally minimize noise and create
space the perfect platform bed frame
just got better you can now customize
the bed by choosing between the original
pillow board or the new solid wood
headboard the fabric pillow board adds
softness and color to any space while
the headboard offers solid Sleek support
the headboard attaches directly to the
bed using Japanese is joinery with no
tools required you can buy it with the
bed or on its own as an upgrade it's
made for how you live so the bed by
thuma is backed with a lifetime warranty
it ships right to your door in three
easy to maneuver boxes and it takes
about five minutes to set up um to
assemble with no tools required you can
easily build it yourself Jacqui if you
could attest to that because I know you
have a thuma bed and snitches room of
your house
I do and not only does seeing it bring
me such Joy because I can sing thuma
every time I see it but the best part
about the thuma beds are that they're so
easy to assemble it's really meant for a
lay person but they're also made with
such quality materials and they look so
gorgeous and stunning and like
minimalist which is such the vibe that
I'm curating right now and I have
immensely enjoyed every aspect of having
a thuma bed in my house I would highly
highly recommend
along with the bed they offer other
bedroom Essentials um like the mattress
the nightstand the side table and
they're all designed to perfectly
complement the bed
they also work with one tree planted so
they plant a tree for every bed and
nightstand that they sell all of their
Essentials are green guard gold
certified and they're intentional less
is more design Philosophy for the room
has clean lines subtle curves and life
enhancing details create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit Towards the bed
um towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US so
that's thuma t-h-u-m-a dot Co
slash toast thuma.com
toast for 25 credit
great okay our next story Megan the
stallion says she's got to take a break
following her home burglary so Megan the
stallion performed on SNL this weekend
and while she was in New York her home
was burglarized uh what the [ __ ] the
thieves took off with 300 to 400 000 in
cash electronics and jewelry please have
not made an arrest yet but they do have
video footage of the incident so she
wrote on Twitter saying material things
can be replaced but I'm glad everyone is
safe hotties I'm really sorry but after
SNL I really got to take a break I'm so
tired physically and emotionally oh my
God what the [ __ ] like because I was
just watching The Bling Ring documentary
it just feels like
very prevalent in my mind right now like
what the [ __ ] like why can't people stop
robbing other people like go leave
everyone a [ __ ] alone yeah
that is so sad because it's not it's not
about the material items celebrities
have insurance and of course whatever
the sense of peace that gets robbed from
you when someone invades your home and
the fear it instills in you is so
crippling and nobody feels bad for you
because you're a celebrity but like I do
because I'm a human being and I think
like if you're if you're ever inclined
to Rob someone's house like you're
[ __ ] delusional stop stop right and
also I feel like you know we talk about
this the new cycle moves on but right
person like lives with this trauma
for a very long time and nobody cares to
acknowledge it because like you know you
think celebrities don't deserve rights
because they're rich like that's the
culture like oh they're fine they'll
just you know get more security and buy
another thing and it's not about that no
it's not about that anyways I'm glad
she's taking a break
um if she needs one normalize taking
breaks when you're at the height of your
career like it's okay we will all still
be here waiting and be fans when you
come back I know I just feel like when
you're part of that hustle culture you
get such bad anxiety because like
staying relevant is the key to your
success and so like taking time off and
stepping back from the spotlight is
literally like the scariest thing you
can do I think when you're building your
career oh for sure but
if you are like supremely talented the
cream always Rises and like you'll be
back doing your thing in no time and you
just have to like trust in yourself that
you could do that but you also like
can't get to where you need to be if you
are running on no fuel no and Meg the
stallion I think is like a mainstay I
think she'll be like in history like one
of the biggest female rappers of all
time exactly she could take a break she
can take a break and we will all still
be here ready and waiting when she's
ready to come back I was asleep during
her SNL so I didn't get to watch but I
heard rave reviews and she did both I
think people who can do both are so it's
like such a flex it's such a flex those
are like the coolest episodes it's like
100 yours yeah no it's just like cool
like yeah I'm known for my singing But
like I can be funny and act and read off
a cue card like it's such a shape
why reading off a cue card is hard I was
saying that seriously oh okay it is hard
it'll be easier to memorize it honestly
like cue cards you have to like look at
the camera but then also your cue card
that was not me being shady I'm sorry no
I was not knocking that it is a true
talent to like act while reading a cue
card
um I just think it's like such a flex on
all the other hosts like it's the
coolest thing
yeah
that I think that moment is uh ruined a
bit when your home is burglarized just a
tad just a tad uh but I'm glad she's
taking a break and more people should
take breaks maybe you should call Harry
Styles and let him know that he just
breaks gotta take a break my policeman
hslot you know who Charlie took a break
after Ariana Grande yeah yeah she took a
very nice long break and look we're uh
so ready for her whenever there was
there was a two three year process where
like she would not take a break and she
was going through so much in her
personal life and it was really sad to
watch and she was breaking down on stage
and she just would not stop it's like
someone let this girl take a nap she got
married and finally took a nap and I
feel like she's been like off the radar
for like over a year and I feel like
it's so good for her and she knows REM
Beauty she does
but yeah but it's like different key
stuff that lets her sleep in her own bed
at night right and that's also different
than doing like an album and a tour at
the same time and I feel like it's been
so good for I feel like she's also
working on Wicked rehearsals right now
which is in LA and she gets to still be
at home with her husband she's like a
really good work-life balance yeah I
can't talk about Wicked because it's
coming out in Far four years too far and
in two parts so like I don't even want
to get my hopes up okay we don't have to
talk about that but something I just
wanted to say is you know once uh every
year I am reminded that Ariana Grande is
married like it's so random and I always
forget I always remember it's like
always one of the first things I
remember about her I don't know why I
think it's hard because he's like a
nobody you know which is great which is
great you would love a business banbo
speaking of marriage are you ready for
our next story yes Robert Kraft marries
Dana blumberg in star-studded Surprise
we're at wedding
another ring New England Patriots owner
Robert Kraft married Dr Dana blumberg in
a star-studded surprise wedding in New
York City on Friday night page six has
learned uh the billionaire and 47 81
year old billionaire and 47 year old
doctor invited guests to a kickoff and a
touchdown party at the hall de Lumiere
in lower Manhattan and told them to
dress festively but did not disclose
that they'd be tying the knot so people
came to this party not knowing what to
expect turns out it is a wedding they
had like being rich is so sick yeah a
few fun facts one Elton John performed
and they had met Elton John a few years
ago and like Elton had said like
whenever you guys do get married I would
like to perform for you as a gift and so
then Elton gave them a few dates that
worked for him and that's how they chose
not them planning their whole wedding
around Elton John they also had it at
the hall de Lumiere which right now is
showing the Gustav Klimt exhibition
which is the woman in gold
you know her is that supposed to mean
something to me yeah you haven't seen
the movie The Woman in gold
no
one thing about me is like I know
nothing about art like do you know the
story about the women in gold
I'm assuming it was a woman who wore
gold okay let me let me give you just a
brief synopsis because it's a it's a
good story so uh Clint is an artist and
the woman in gold is one of his pieces
he won uh a prominent Jewish Family
commissioned it in the uh like over 100
years ago and it passed down through
their family but then when the Nazis
took over they stole that piece of art
after the war the family like took like
took the trial to try and get their art
back that's a picture of literally their
aunt Adele and it's theirs they oh you
know what this does sound familiar Helen
Mirren it plays daughter and so Clint is
the artist who made that piece and his
exhibition is at um is displaying right
now in lower New York so the whole they
rented out the exhibition for five days
so then wow wedding like was surrounded
and that's beautiful
you know what's so funny about this
wedding is like obviously you see them
he's like 1 000 years old and she's like
this vivacious blonde like she is almost
50 like it's like not that crazy no it's
not that crazy and she's a doctor she's
like New York's top right she's not like
a harlot like right it's not what you
think you're looking it's a kind of like
a really appropriate marriage when you
look at them you don't see it because
she's like blonde and like really fit
and like she looks 25 right
but no it's a kind of romantic yeah it's
like if I wanted to do a surprise
wedding I'd be like hi guys I'm throwing
a party like no one would come that's
the thing I'd be like wait no it's my
wedding and then they'll be like oh yeah
sure I'll come you know what I mean
right no but
he must throw a great party right now
Tom Brady was there so no Giselle yeah
it's like it's real like I know
I'm accepting it in my own I've just
yeah I've just entered the stage of
acceptance yeah which is good and I
think this I don't think they
intentionally did it this way but like
this rollout rollout is giving me time
to process as opposed to if they just
all of a sudden one day put out a
statement I would be like what yeah yeah
like shock shock and awe yeah
so really sweet wedding news
happy for you know that I am are you
ready for our fifth and final story
which is like some confusing divorce
news yes
so people put out a story yesterday that
uh it wasn't just people but there was
like an official report it went to every
Outlet Monique Samuels and her husband
Chris Samuels are divorcing period like
no questions asked I was so upset when I
saw it like I literally wanted to cry
for the Samuels is but then Monique and
Chris went on Instagram and appeared to
hit back at rumors that they were
splitting after 10 years of marriage she
flashed their wedding bands in the video
that she posted um she said that she had
just gotten back from hiking all day and
then turned to Chris and asked Chris
what do you have to say about all this
and he said shop Mila Eve in response
referring to Monique's I'm in store then
Monique flashes her wedding rings Mila
Eve that's funny that is funny directly
literally Jackie that's so us no so us
but then she says no better Source than
the actual Source you all already know
how I roll I give my own damn exclusives
and then she prompted fans to tune into
her YouTube show Monday evening
okay I'm like glad they're not divorced
but like I do feel like they might have
been like
poking us like like this is giving PR I
feel like they might be trying to just
save the announcement till their show
tonight on YouTube
because
oh I mean I guess we'll find out tonight
we'll find out tonight I'll be so upset
because they're not like they're just
flashing their Rings like and they're
saying they're kind of like joking about
it but they didn't say explicitly like
where yeah but they're together in their
house chilling like married people do
yeah divorced people don't act like that
most of the time right I I mean
I'll be so upset I'll be heartbroken I
will be so upset the way that like I
feel like they are literally
picture-perfect American family like
please no please no first t'challa and
now this no no we can't handle it I hope
that tonight's Monday
um YouTube is just a fun enough meaning
literal like Mindless episode of
whatever it is that they do on their
YouTube channel yeah not them just
pushing up the news till they can
announce it themselves because she said
I give my own damn exclusives
oh I didn't see it like that but like
it's just an alternative way of thinking
about it I feel like it's fine like I
feel like they're totally fine like I
believe in love me too
and that's just a little bit about me
well those are the past five stories
feel as though you needed to know them
you certainly needed to know them but
you also need to know our thoughts on
the penultimate I can't stop saying that
word episode of The House of the Dragon
which premiered on HBO last night and is
brought to you by figs I have to tell
you
the day of my show in Nashville I went
to The Cheesecake Factory for lunch of
course you know eating the local Cuisine
and I ran into like a million toasters
on their lunch breaks and they were all
wearing figs I'm like did you use code
they're like toast yeah I did it was so
funny every because they all work in
like medical sales and you know uh
Med Spas so like they all are wearing
scrubs and every like it's the air Maze
of the medical industry obsessed so
everybody has something they look
forward to in the fall if you're in
healthcare there's something extra
exciting on the horizon for you because
the brand new fall colors and styles
from figs just dropped if you haven't
heard figs makes the comfiest scrubs
around and they are toaster tested
toaster approved they're engineered with
Innovative technical Comfort technology
to be ridiculously soft and Incredibly
durable so you're always ready to take
on the day in style so their scrubs are
100 awesome because they focus on design
function and comfort so they're super
super soft they have a proprietary
four-way stretch fabric so if you've got
to do a lunge you know bend over to the
cabinet bend over to hear a patient's
heartbeat you're being taken care of in
your figs the material is moisture
wicking and anti-wrinkle and anti-odor
thanks to the silvador antimicrobial
technology so you know part of being in
healthcare is working super long shifts
and sometimes after those shifts like
you're not going to smell the best but
Biggs is out here protecting you and
those pits they have up to 20 pockets on
some of their Styles stethoscope in
Band-Aid in I don't know any other like
medical supplies um
ointment
ointment yes and you can also customize
your figs with text and icon embroidery
if you don't know where to start you can
pick up a set in one of their new fall
colors that are super great and will
look awesome all season long they're
popular core scrubs never go out of
style and are easy to mix and match I'm
pretty sure that's what I saw all the
toasters at the Cheesecake Factory
wearing very kind of slimming black on
most of them and it was the core scrub
figs believes that the awesome humans in
healthcare deserve awesome scrubs to
match head to where figs.com use code
toast to get 15 off your first order
that's
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s.com promo code toast
great
okay so the morning after the King dies
and it's like all hell has broken loose
they're being so [ __ ] evil the high
tower is like locking everyone in their
rooms trying to come up with a plan so
that renera doesn't find out that he's
dead and they can successfully usurp the
throne Before Sunrise yes only problem
the king cannot be found right what did
the little boy run and tell his mom I
believe that the King was dead
but Allison knew
no he didn't tell his mom he told the
snitch Talia
and then Talia went to go tell him
got it got it that's what I think I or
maybe that like his uh that aegon wasn't
there
like where's Dad
um you know oh that's good too I don't
think it really matters I was just like
waiting I thought it was like aegon did
something horrible or I thought maybe it
was a flashback to a young aegon like I
didn't know because the episode just
started with that little kid yeah it was
a little confusing I don't think there's
anything more to it but I just didn't
know like what was being told
so nobody no you know what it was you're
right your first thing was right he told
Talia that the king is dead because then
Talia told Allison and the spymaster
wormwood a [ __ ] yeah a bad actress
[ __ ] worse than ever last night worse
than ever even though I did appreciate
her mission that oh my God ring of child
Fighters sharpening their teeth and
their fingernails that was horrible and
aegon is really really sick
bastards all over town I so agree in one
moment I was like oh my God what are
these like child abusers doing in King's
Landing and then in the next moment like
she's advocating for them and I was like
queen Queen no and it's like the way
Otto goes back on it like not that I
have anything left to give to him but
like his word means nothing honestly
the way that aegon does not want to be
king would be a horrible King and
everyone knows how sick twisted
unethical and disgusting he is yet we're
all bending over backwards like killing
all these nice people just so aegon
could take the throne it's so stupid to
me I hate the [ __ ] high Towers
Allison at least like
expresses she has a conscience yeah
she's not all evil I actually think
she's like struggling with all of this
yeah I think that here's what I
regardless of if viserys was uh said
what he said before he died the hot uh
Otto and his was doing it anyway doing
it anyway so that's good to know that it
didn't change that much the only thing
that changed was Allison's participation
yeah because if he hadn't said that she
would have been going to bat for rain
era but since he said that she's on the
fence you know I know it's episode nine
and we should have done this from the
beginning but I'd like to
um Crown a weenie of the week every week
because last night it was Sir Christian
the way I hate this [ __ ] loser the
way he killed that guy for speaking
facts speaking [ __ ] facts and
being the only person in the room with
ethics and morals I hate sir Kristen
Cole so much he's obsessed with Allison
he's such a loser follower loser first
it was raining
[ __ ] whipped he definitely yeah some
like mommy issues yes because he doesn't
have a mind of his own and he's so
[ __ ] fanatic and extreme like get a
life so extreme it's like calm down it's
not that deep it's like a show man yeah
no he's such a [ __ ] loser like even
the way like a couple episodes ago he
started that fight
um with the Harren hall guy in the yard
over the prince like he's such a loser
I'm so glad also they recast aegon again
right this is our first time meeting
this ago no he was there last week yeah
I remember I I had the other aegon the
like two episodes the one who was
jerking off two episodes ago into the
window yes yes no I think we saw this
guy last week that's what he's expecting
to see under the table
no I that guy looked like kind of
familiar like I'd seen him before okay
okay good
um
the only the good news is though about
aegon is like he's only one keeping us
from amond on the throne I know I
thought a Monde was gonna kill a God be
worse than aegon amond is a Joffrey yeah
I think amond is evil and I think aegon
is stupid I also know I like that
viserys is being called viserys the
peaceful because that is what he was
that is what he was even though I did
feel like the second he got crowned me
and Ben were like guessing I thought he
was like gonna kill himself because like
this is his worst nightmare come true
but then when he heard people cheering
for him it's like literally it's
addictive yeah I just I do believe that
the people in King's Landing give a [ __ ]
about who the king is like they're all
like I felt like when they were cheering
like they don't care no they do not care
and they say this all the time in Game
of Thrones that like they don't care
like it's all these like Seven Kingdoms
who are warring with each other for a
seat that doesn't change the lives of
the people whatsoever but yeah I think
they like were forced into this place it
turns into a pretty good concert hey we
have a new king rah-rah he seems excited
we're excited and I was like damn this
is addictive like uh what's his face is
about to have like a power trip and yeah
came through yeah
I been away take back every negative
thing everything I've said about her
because now obviously she's hopping on
her Dragon to go alert Rainier about
what's gone down the only thing that was
missing was a little tricaris on these
hoes I know she could have ended it all
right there but you know what that would
have been exactly what she was
advocating against because she's not
evil like no but she told Allison like
obviously you can't kill Rainier and her
children if she killed Allison and her
children she's just as bad as what she
was trying to avoid so so it was a
really good it was a really good episode
given the fact that Rainier and Damon
were not even in it and I didn't even
get to see my boyfriend last night like
that was upsetting
but it was good nonetheless it was
really good only because yet Auntie came
through no that's the thing about
aunties like you can always count on
them yeah and you might count them out
but never count out the Countess they're
always going to be with you there I
wasn't entirely sure
whether I think they wanted us to guess
for a second if it was going to be
rainis or Rainier I don't know how
renira would have found out but they
showed her hustling down the stairs
right and when she looks up when she's
in the crowd I think she realized
they're going to the dragon pit and she
was like thank you you're taking me
exactly where I wanted to go to get my
baby boy
like remember when she's being like with
the mob and she looks up to see the
streets they're on I don't know why she
was smiling me too finally found her
Handler she knew right then and there
they're going to the dragon pit I can
get my my dragon okay and let's talk
about those two brothers like the one
that bailed out raynes and the two
obsessed but like my god do they suck at
their job like literally he lost my
niece in the first four seconds of
getting her out of the the castle oh
yeah but uh in the previews for next
week which is not a spoiler uh because
they're at War now and Rainier and Damon
are in the episode
um the brother who refused to
save aegon
um goes to Rainier's side
I just feel tea no and like when they
hanged that man who was trying to escape
and go tell Rainier like it was giving
like North Korea
uh yeah that was quite upset that was
upsetting especially because it's like
when the other guys like they stood
their ground and they were like when we
stand with Rainier the two people who
did and it's like well what if one of
you just like pretended to and then went
back to the other side and it's like
that's what he did that's what would
happen okay now we literally notice is
literally [ __ ] disgusting
Littlefinger I hate him he needs to be
the first to Die the feet that was C
that was new that was new but you had to
it makes sense he's giving he's doing
all this [ __ ] for her why right right no
he's a [ __ ] freak he's a [ __ ]
freak
such a good episode but like need my
girly back like ring Mira Damon where
are you
also the daughter wife
is like a prophet you know you see that
she said there's a beneath a beast beast
beneath yes
apparently in the other episodes that
she was in she was like saying a bunch
of stuff that didn't make sense to us
but they were all like prophecies she
like knows [ __ ]
what is there's a beast beneath the
floor I mean rhaenys rainys and her
Beast got it got it like when he was
literally beneath the boards
oh yes pay attention to whatever she's
saying got it okay sister slash wife
um also the real house has a Potomac was
on last night quite literally nothing
happened except the way that Ashley and
Gisele are being so [ __ ] dramatic I
definitely thought it was weird that he
sent the message and then once I found
out he worked there I'm like that's not
weird
I've got to be honest I didn't watch
because I was immensely enjoying my book
and I was like you missed nothing it's
it's I'm sure it'll be a great season
but like it's a super slow build
basically Ashley was posting that she
was out all night and when she woke up
the next morning she had a message from
Chris Bassett
wait is it basset
the set Bessette right because when I
say Chris Bassett and then I say Candace
Dillard Bessette right and when I
introduced her at bravocon last night I
said Candace Dillard Bessette Potomac
Barbie she looked so cute I saw
um whatever he had sent a message like
you should have come to the W and that's
like a weird message to send your wife's
friend at three in the morning but he
just took over as the general manager of
like their Club there he's trying to
make it like cool and he's trying to get
all of Candace's friends to come so it
gets not weird so Ashley like brought it
up and was trying to make it a thing and
then Giselle was like you know last year
at the reunion when we broke for like
snack he came into my dressing room and
I was all alone and I was really
uncomfortable and he was just
complaining about his wife
and Robin was like did he touch you or
do anything she's like no and Robin was
like
so you're just being dramatic like their
Rob is actually proud of Robin for
getting her ahead out of giselle's ass
for two seconds to being like you're
being so [ __ ] dramatic like they're
trying to make it a thing it's not a
thing and this is not my newfound
Candace Dillard beset stanhood it's just
facts like stop being dramatic yeah
that was the only thing that happened
then they went and did a dance class
with Charisse and I just [ __ ] hate
Charisse Charisse is back yeah and they
like
she keeps trying to like have lunch with
Karen Huger and Karen huger's not
interested and all the ladies are saying
it's because like Charice has like some
big T on Karen
and I'm just not interested I'm not
looking for anyone to expose Karen like
she's America's sweetheart like leave
her alone yeah leave her alone everyone
tries to comfort and it's like people
who come into Beverly Hills and they
just go for Sutton like it's not gonna
work it's not gonna work for the fans no
she's not gonna work for you
um so those were the TV Recaps uh
right yeah uh you caught up and tell me
lies I did I did
um I found this episode to be
particularly Dreadful yes my patience
with the show is wearing fins and
there's only two more episodes left how
are we gonna wrap it all up like I'm
glad we got like a villain origin story
from Pippa a little bit because she was
pissing me the [ __ ] off by being such a
loser wannabe like pick me girl yeah
like when she was like ironically like
about the movie she's just like kind of
like a loser and that yeah that's it
that's her truth yes I like her and I um
I understand her I'm team Pippa as
opposed to Lucy I mean Lucy's like my
least favorite person aside from myself
I know I'm just like so over the show
like I'm not invested in anyone's
relationship except for Brie and Evan
and we didn't even get Brie and Evan
content what do we want Brevin when do
we want it now and we know that they get
married so great everyone else can like
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off yeah but I do hope
Wrigley could find love too because he
really loves Pippa and I don't know she
needs to like find herself is the thing
like maybe yeah I think she struggles
with her sexuality a little bit yeah and
like just knowing like who she is and
what she wants but Wrigley like loves so
purely and so passionately and he
deserves a nice girl I love him yeah
too and he's like not he doesn't have a
mean bonus in his body whereas everyone
around him is like plotting he's just
living his life doing football with the
Bros trying his best look trying to look
after his brother trying to look after
his brother so another episode of that
this week part two of the Beverly Hills
reunion which we will talk about
um on Wednesday and Kardashians so
winter house premiered
um I'm not watching I might watch the
first episode to see if I'm feeling
anything
um
we shall see I don't think I'm gonna
watch I'm I'm feeling good about where
I'm at like with my content that's good
yeah
so that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the toast the Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you are watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so on Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I got rid of castbox all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the toast and leave a
five-star review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are Jacqui have an
amazing day love you dearly and I'll see
you tomorrow love you talk to you in
five minutes 100 bye talk to you guys
tomorrow love ya bye